- Do you notice that
I'm hitting the button
and my glove, it doesn't light up?
Does anyone else notice that?
Is this rigged?
- The competition is hot,
right here, right now.
(upbeat drum music)
- Woo!
I'm here with Emily Blunt, give it up!
(mimics ham horn)
There are a lot of lyrics
in all of those songs, okay?
- Hey, this is your show, it's your game.
(Kelly laughing)
- Lamborghini.
(alarm buzzing)
- Mercedes.
- Lincoln.
(alarm buzzing)
- Ford.
- Buick.
(alarm buzzing)
- Dodge.
- Tesla.
(alarm buzzing)
- Oh!
I was so impressed.
(buzzer buzzing)
(Kelly screaming)
Is that the time?
Wait, I didn't know there was a time!
I had one, Ford!
I had one.
- [Voice Of God] Now,
now, come on, my child.
Calm down.
(audience laughing)
Did you just change it?
- I'm going correct.
(all laughing)
(ham horn blaring)
- Look, I'm gonna pass it.
I'm gonna win one.
I'm gonna do one.
I just wanna try one.
I just wanna make one,
I just wanna make one.
Oh!
I can't do anything sports ball.
- [Voice Of God] This show
is completely out of control.
(all laughing)
- Silence.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Now, Kelly, you and Ken can both buzz in
when you think you know what this item is
that I will use now.
(bell dinging)
Kelly.
- Hairbrush?
- [Matt] I'm sorry?
- Like a,
- A hairbrush?
That is incorrect.
Ken, you can.
(bell dinging)
- Sounds like the bristles.
- Oh, it's like, the little popper things
on the popping thing?
- Oh my gosh!
- Bubble wrapping!
(audience cheering)
- I'm so bad at this!
- [Matt] Ken Jeong is money!
(upbeat pop music)
(audience cheering)
- [Ken] I'm gonna strut, I'm
gonna strut, every time I win!
I'm gonna strut!
- Oh my God, wait, I just
remembered something.
Wait, I remembered, I think last time,
I think last time I played this game,
I thought everything was a hairbrush.
- You did, you did,
and as I recall, you lost
that time, but. (laughs)
Okay, are you guys ready?
- [Emily] Yeah, yeah.
- [Matt] Here comes your sound.
- [Akbar] All right, here we go.
(bag crinkling)
(bell dinging)
Whoa, how'd you know that so fast?
- A brush?
(buzzer buzzing)
- Not a brush.
- [Emily] Do it again.
It sounds the same.
(bell dinging)
- Brush?
(buzzer buzzing)
- What is up, do you have
a thing with brush, no!
- Are you okay?
- [Akbar] Did you brush your hair today?
- Sometimes when you're out there singing,
you don't always remember
the words to songs,
which is literally every
tour I've ever done.
Does that happen to you?
- No.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh!
- I'm just kidding, I'm kidding!
- I'm so intimidated, I
just started sweating!
I'm so bad at lyrics, okay.
It's time to find out who is
better or worse with lyrics
in a game called "Lyrically Challenged".
♪ Lyrically challenged, yeah ♪
(upbeat band music)
♪ Dashing through the snow
in a one horse open sleigh ♪
♪ O'er the fields we go, laughing
all the way, ha, ha, ha ♪
♪ Bells on bobtail ring,
making spirits bright ♪
♪ What fun it is to ride and
sing a sleighing song tonight ♪
♪ Oh, jingle bells, Batman
smells, Robin laid an egg ♪
♪ The Batmobile ♪
(buzzer buzzing)
- Wait, wait!
- Remix!
I think that's canon.
(audience cheering)
- I was like, no, this is the best part,
that was a really good defense,
or offensive, because I
was like, "I know that one,
"but I don't know all
the lyrics to that one."
- I feel like this is in your wheelhouse
because it's by the
legendary Whitney Houston.
- [Kelly] Oh, I got it.
- It's "I Wanna Dance With Somebody".
And once again, the music will be here,
Lin doesn't need the music.
- I have to sing Whitney
opposite Kelly Clarkson, what's happening?
This is a living nightmare.
- [Kelly] I'm so ready.
♪ I think you're really great ♪
♪ And I don't know what comes next ♪
(audience cheering)
- You went for flattery, I like it.
If I didn't win Whitney, I
would've gone home crying.
- What cutting device might
you see going back and forth
in someone's front of house?
- [Heidi] Land mower!
- What?
A what?
- A lawn mower!
- [Winnie] A lawn mower!
- Oh, I was like, what did you,
did you say a land mower?
- [Winnie] I'm so happy
I'm not playing this game.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
You're gonna get your picture on the wall.
- Heidi too!
- Just for land mower, going on the wall.
- Come on, Kelly, you gotta catch up!
- [Kelly] I, honestly, I don't know-
- Next question!
- [God] Name the movie
in which the Fresh Prince
punches an alien and then
welcomes it to earth.
(alarm buzzing)
- Yes, I was quicker, "Men In Black"!
"Men In Black", yes!
(buzzer buzzer)
- [God] I'm sorry, Kelly, that is wrong.
(audience cheering)
I love seeing you get
all excited like that.
That was fun for me,
but you was wrong, girl.
- Wait, what?
- Was it "Independence Day"?
- [Kelly] Will Smith and aliens?
- [God] That is correct,
Demi, Demi has it.
- That was a trick, Lord,
and I am angry about it.
That was a trick, isn't Will
Smith in "Men In Black"?
- [Audience] Yes.
- [Kelly] See, that was a trick!
- [God] Well, I work in
mysterious ways, don't I, Kelly?
- Yeah.
- First lyric.
Hanging out the passenger's side of my-
(alarm buzzing)
- Who did it first?
♪ Of my best friend's ride ♪
- No, it's me, it's me!
- Uh-uh!
I do it first!
- All right, but what's
the name of the song?
- "Scrubs".
♪ I don't want no scrub ♪
- [Kandi] She beat me on my own song!
That is crazy!
- This is deeply hard for Kandi,
because Kandi, tell them
why that's a burden on you.
- Because I wrote those lyrics.
(audience cheering)
♪ Hanging out the passenger's
side of his best friend's ride ♪
- You did a good job.
- I could sing the whole verse to that.
- Hey, you know what, I could
sing the whole song, man.
You did a good job,
but I hit it first, so.
Our button was not working, guys!
- Our button was, we
got another two points.
- Paul Bunyan used one of these.
- Axe.
(bell dinging)
(audience cheering)
Oh my Gosh, what!
- Okay, okay.
- Hold on, hold on.
She pays the producers!
- No, I have never seen anyone.
I have never seen a thing.
- Here's the next one.
This X-man has claws.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Yeah!
- You know it!
- Wolverine.
- Yeah!
(bell dinging)
Bring it in!
Yes!
- It's not, yeah, I know,
you have to get closer.
- I love that he's, like, so tall,
I'm, like, doing this to his belly button.
- It's a belly button bounce right there.
Hold on, go sideways to the camera.
- It's like, it's like,
this is our. (laughs)
- So the game is hit the button
whether you have it or not.
- Let's keep going.
If you pass gas, you'd likely say-
- Come on!
- Cut the cheese!
(bell dinging)
- What in the world, oh my gosh!
- It's not a game anymore,
it's rigged.
- We are on fire!
This is how you win, this is how you win!
(Kelly laughing)
What?
I am so crazy talented.
(all laughing)
- Oh, she's our favorite
person, she taught me to knit.
- Meryl Streep!
(bell dinging)
- Ah!
- Okay, this is what you hop
on to go around New York City.
- Subway!
(bell dinging)
- The L,
- Subway!
I said subway!
- Underground.
- She can't hear me, I said subway!
Oh, this, oh, this is Tex-Mex.
It's, oh, how do you describe it?
- Chili con carne!
- It's runny and you dip chips in it.
- Oh,
it's a nacho?
- You dip chips in it,
and it kind of, what's on nachos?
- Guacamole?
- Oh, God, pass, pass, pass!
Oh, bzz.
- Fly.
- Yes!
(audience laughing)
(bell dinging)
- I'm sitting down, where's my shoe?
Oh no, I fell down, I fell down.
Oh, no, I'm rolling.
Rolling Stones. (laughs)
I don't know what.
Break, break.
Break, oh, rock and roll, rock and roll.
Rock and roll?
Break?
Kelly Clarkson, hey,
American, what's happening?
Singing, performing?
(buzzer buzzing)
Rockstar?
(beep)
(audience laughing)
- Oh, God!
- I'm just curious.
- Break, break dancing!
- Oh my God, you say break dancing?
(upbeat disco music)
(audience cheering)
(Kelly screaming)
(ham horn blaring)
- I knew it!
- That's what I'm talking about,
that's what I'm talking about,
that's what I'm talking about!
(audience cheering)
Yes!
- No!
- Wait, I got this, it's okay!
Our side, I'm gonna renovate
all your houses, so!
(audience cheering)
(Kelly screaming)
- [Akbar] I saw you!